it was it was a bit tough i'll just you
know as an aside because we've got um
you know obviously big stories without
cheese resignation but also the war and
they're like very distinct and so like
trying to
segue between them is not really
possible
but we'll jump to this one from the
post-millennial
seattle children's hospital offers
medicalized gender transition to
nine-year-olds quote we accept new
patients ages 9 to 16 the site reads
patients ages 17 and older and patients
who have not yet started puberty will be
directed to community resources
this is part of a long-standing story a
long chain of stories boston's
children's boston children's hospital
big controversy surrounding that the
media claiming there's threats going
their way you've got i think now a
hospital in chicago performing these uh
these transitions for minors and now we
have the latest story from
post-millennial that seattle is doing
the same thing
i know that um
there was recently a a board review in
florida the medical board did a review
of uh
sex change operations for children and
and medical and other transitions
uh i supposed to throw it to you uh joe
you probably know better what's going on
with florida as
it pertains to child gender transition
well you know florida is taking an
unequivocal stand that is just there
with the data
it's not very dissimilar it's actually
worse in terms of evidence you know we
had the mass discussion previously
at least a study showed you know a
reduction from 12 to 11 percent which is
a 10 reduction i mean if if you really
think that that's enough to force people
to do things you know we can have a
conversation about that but in this case
the data
you know the data are even they're just
they're incredibly weak i mean there's
basically
and it
speaks to dishonesty so the cdc quotes
that
extremely
unimpressive mask study and says oh this
shows that you can actually reduce
community transmission
then and so you know which like to to
someone who looked at it
they would say that doesn't make sense
in this case it's the same thing the
data you know people advocates say that
oh it's this is the standard of care and
it work it helps people you know it
makes them less likely to commit suicide
and things like that but the data
actually don't show that at all
so for for uh
we did we did a members-only segment
where we read detransitioner statements
yeah and there were a lot of teenage
women because i think it's like
overwhelmingly teenage girls who are
getting these surgeries uh double
mastectomies and things like that at
least there was there was actually one
study from the nih we pulled up showing
that 90
of what they reviewed were double
mastectomies on
on females and the average age i think
was like 15 or something like that
so
we read these stories where they're
they're suicidal it's it's horrifying
no no no i mean like the idea here is
i think there's something happening i do
i think i think gender dysphoria is real
i think there are kids who are
transgender and i think we have to pay
attention to
there was one um
article i read last week from psychology
today
a phd researcher saying
we know that phthalates and pcbs
are our hormone disruptors
he he cited a study showing that certain
birth control had a masculinizing effect
on female fetuses on their brains and it
resulted in women who preferred the
company of women and
did not prefer childbearing and things
like that
and so that point was
there's an environmental factor coming
from the chemicals and the
pharmaceuticals we use that is likely
contributing to this
i think that's true i mean i think even
alex jones has pointed that out he's
mocked for it when he mentioned talked
about atrazine
and so i think the result there is okay
we need to figure that out stop that but
this does mean they're going to be trans
kids and how do we effectively solve for
this problem how do we make sure these
kids are going to be happy healthy not
suicidal and the issue seems to be
the the accepted medical treatment
across the country united states is at
odds with what europe is now doing with
the scandinavian countries who have
rejected all of this stuff and the end
result for a lot of these people i'm not
saying all of them
we're seeing them post online saying
after undergoing these surgeries and
these medical treatments they are worse
than they were before
yeah that's that's a scary outcome and
we want to prevent that we want to make
sure that kids who are suffering from
dysphoria or whatever the issue may be
hormone disruptors be it the case how do
we help them when you've got
these extreme policies that are all
going in one way and ignoring the
science that we can see in other places
no it's a great summary and you're
absolutely right they're definitely boys
who think feel like they're girls girls
who feel like they're boys that's that's
like that's nothing there's nothing new
there
but that's a different and i agree with
you right understanding trying to do
what we can to understand why that is
that's an important goal
but that is a
different issue than what to do about in
terms of medical or surgical therapies
and standards of professional care and
that's the issue that florida is focused
on and standards of professional care
you know it's just i've actually i mean
i you know covet before this like i was
a mainstream
doctor researcher
very mainstream right i you know like
and i i did you know fortunately i did
well but i was there was nothing
controversial about me
and since covet it's just opened my eyes
to
examples of medical organizations just
completely misleading people and
essentially in some cases lying in this
particular case
at the end of the day
you have
experimental therapies right that are
not vitamin d like these are just
serious and real quick not fda approved
treatments for these kids i'm not sure
that i mean i don't know that the fda
authorizes medical therapies they
certainly are authorized drugs and
devices but i i don't think that they
authorize me my understanding is correct
if i'm wrong i think you know this
lupron is not fda approved it's it's
off-label use yeah as a puberty blocker
so that's what i have heard i don't know
if i'm correct there it isn't i believe
that's correct yeah my point is some
cancer this is this is
really fun to point out
uh lupron is can you someone want to
check that real quick i want to make
sure we get this right because my
understanding is it is an off-label use
as a puberty blocker in kids
yeah off label is not actually that's
not a big deal doctors can
prescribe things off label and they do
it all the time except there are some
things you can't what does off label
mean
well
off actually well off label means that
you know the fda when they approve a
drug they approve it for specific
indications if a drug company wants to
expand the indications you know they
have to provide data give it to the fda
and the fda has to approve it for that
new indication so that's how that
without runs off label first it's off
label so my point here is and without
mentioning any other treatments other
than this because we don't you know my
point is
there are
mainstream narratives
that if you mention off-label use on
some drugs you're a dangerous conspiracy
theorist meanwhile the narrative from
the establishment is to actively promote
this particular off-label use
which we are seeing notifications of and
they're kind of devastating for a lot of
these kids so ultimately i think
you mentioned it the hypocrisy the lies
and all that it's all here my question
is
what is florida doing differently and so
i guess i wanted to get this very very
much at the beginning i i watched the
live stream where the medical board was
discussing this what ended up happening
with that
well the medical board
basically you know their their task that
day was to decide whether they were
going to take on the issue because right
now essentially it's an unregulated
space right you've got different centers
you know who are there you go seattle
children's hospital nine years old right
some hospitals they may not see patients
until they're 14 or 15
some refuse to do surgery or say they're
not going to do surgery unless they're
at least 18. so different you know
different practices at different places
and the board of medicine in florida
said that they were going to look at
that and the goal really from in my in
my opinion should be that they that they
stop these therapies
in children who are under 18 unless
there's evidence and i'll just say
really quickly right people make things
so complicated and confusing
at the end of the day right you've got
high risk procedures right puberty
blockers when the brain is developing at
a young age
sex change operations mastectomies the
risk of infertility sterility high risk
not vitamin d not other off-label drugs
and you've got
uncertain benefit like no one knows
people will tell you with a straight
face that they know it's gonna help they
don't know that not just that we have 37
000 almost 40 000 people on a forum d
trans where there are prominent posts
every day yeah of people saying they are
suicidal now i don't want these people
to feel that way i want them to be happy
and healthy and we have to figure out
how to help them and this certainly is
not resulting in that
well there was maybe some people woman
who spoke at the florida board of
medicine during the public comment
section her name was i think sophia
galvin and she specifically talked about
her experience like as a minor
uh
being incur not i don't want to
encourage what she was when she decided
that she wanted transition her school
was supportive she was the president of
their lgbt community she was encouraged
to undergo a mastectomy she went on
years of testosterone and it was not
happier afterwards and through spiritual
and personal growth ultimately decided
to detransition and is now a really
strong advocate against this i thought
her testimony there was really powerful
i think you're totally right i mean it
was interesting to me that when it was i
think the american academy of pediatrics
uh decided to sort of
block the issue they had doctors saying
that they wanted to talk about it and
they suppressed the motion all of the
doctors there were pointing to studies
from europe that were like look i i
think it's finland just went back to
saying the first treatment for minors
who are experiencing gender dysphoria is
to go through psychotherapy it's not to
me intervene medically i was a
tremendous amount of gaslighting europe
sweden this year released they've been
doing this for years longer than we have
in the united states these gender
transition therapies they released a
their equivalent of sort of the nih
released a new guidance this year and
they said they're not going to do it
anymore for for children because they
just didn't know whether they were doing
more harm than good i think they
literally said that but you have doctors
in
in some in florida who say that no we
know better and you know we're helping
every patient that we see who undergoes
this
i think um
have you have you read about uh
endocrine disruptors and hormone
disruptors sure assuming you have yeah
there was one article that i read that
kind of went viral mentioning
i mentioned it earlier there was a birth
control women would take it and in the
rare chance taking it they still got
pregnant it was having a masculinizing
effect on on their fetuses and if it was
a female you know it was it was causing
issues
i think
when you look at the uh the great words
of uh alex jones they're turning the
freaking frogs gay
but to get more specific and not play
the silly game he was talking about i
think it's a pesticide called atrazine
we've talked about this before there was
a uh there was a study this is like 10
years ago i think showing that it was
interfering with the endocrine systems
of frogs turning ovaries into testes
testing in the ovaries causing a
population collapse and alex pointed
that out
i see stories like that and i'm like
yeah we've long known that there are
like hormones in our drinking water in
cities and plastics are leaching into
our water or you know some people have
argued that soy is doing these things
although i'm not sure that's correct but
okay there's there's probably serious
hormones and hormone disruptors being
consumed and affecting kids who are
developing
so when bill maher says
they're in california they're not in
ohio either we're shaming in them or
creating them i'm like the the argument
from from bill misses a big picture
there i mean it's a fair point he's like
how come in ohio there's not a lot of
trans kids in california there is
it sounds like he's making the point
that it's trendy in california and
probably is
but
my point here is
it could be that california uses
specific chemicals in agriculture that
ohio doesn't and it is causing these
children to become
you know have hormonal imbalance or
disruption in utero which results in
trans kids
that's something we absolutely need to
talk about considering the science is
there to show that's a possibility
so that being said
i think what we're seeing is a mix
i think we're probably seeing a natural
there's a natural phenomenon of people
who are transgender i think that
probably naturally exists in humans to
some degree
i think we're seeing a large uptick in
trans kids probably because of the
pesticides the chemicals the
pharmaceuticals as these other studies
have pointed out and i also think we're
seeing social trends which affect some
kids so the problem is if you approach
this with a one-size-fits-all start with
the surgery then you're going to wrap up
kids who do not need this and create
suicidal teenagers
we probably need to approach this and
figure out what is the underlying cause
of the gender dysphoria in this child is
it a social issue or is it a naturally
you know a developmental issue
i hear you and i i think that
i i it's definitely an interesting
scientific question but i think it's
it's probably not the priority i hear
your your example the you know the
problem is right and
you look at and i totally agree with you
frankly you know i i mean we try and
need organic as much as possible but
it's it's really sad how much junk like
poison really in terms of some of the
pesticides and some of them are hormone
disrupting and some of them increase the
risk of cancer they get into food and
then you've got you know their financial
interests to try and maintain the use of
these chemicals but you look at europe
and my understanding is that they don't
use they don't nearly use nearly the
type of the intensity of pesticides that
we use and they have also seen in some
areas the same explosive growth in terms
particularly in girls who feel like they
should be boys so i you know i i
i hear you and i think that area is
important but i don't think that's what
you know that's what that's not what the
the the focus ought to you think it's
social
social impact i think it's likely that
there's a substantial social component
and it's you know the curves in terms of
the growth it's just not really
consistent with like for example
one of the things that um that's been
noticed is that the age of puberty was
changing right it was getting lower for
different age groups and that was a sort
of a gradual process and that's kind of
how biological processes tend to be
right they're sort of gradual this has
not been gradual this has been explosive
yeah and that or argues less for a
biological mechanism and and at least
you know
growth but it's it could be that there's
a critical mass of phthalates phthalates
or like pesticides or that we've somehow
reached a critical mass we're like you
can eat salt but if you get too much
salt it will kill you like you can't do
over salt will destroy your body so like
if the now the levels of phthalates are
we just hit the ceiling of what we can
handle maybe
i'm not i'm not making those i'm not
trying to prescribe a treatment based on
the idea what i'm what i'm simply trying
to say is
that um for one i oppose sex changes for
kids i i think you've got to be 18
before you start doing this stuff there
is a question about you know the limits
on
when government can intervene to stop
parents from engaging in certain medical
treatments but at certain point you know
i'm just like values
over where you know
my values are we don't give kids sex
change surgeries it's just that that's
where it is for me for whatever reason
but uh my point is
there's likely a natural phenomenon of
of causing gender dysphoria
now i'm not saying we should be giving
kids section surgeries because of it we
clearly look at the scandinavian
countries they're not doing that anymore
but i think the the the issue of the
social factor is also obviously playing
a role whether it's you know you're
saying it's explosive so that's likely
the case either way that's evidence
enough that we should not be doing this
to kids
to ian's point
i think there it's entirely possible
there's a combination of
we were seeing hormone disrupters in in
our food supply plastics or whatever
increasing
but also serious social discouragement
from anyone mentioning it
so it could be
you know the left says there's always
been trans people and the reason there's
a massive explosion of them is because
now it's finally okay for them to speak
up it's like it could actually be both
it could be that in the past 10 years
past 20 years we've massively increased
the amount of pcbs phthalates what is it
poly chloride something i don't know
we've dramatically increased certain
hormones pharmaceuticals plastics and
other things into our food supply that
is their hormone disruptors
but the people who grew up experiencing
that didn't say anything because it was
not socially acceptable now that it is
all of a sudden now there's a perception
that among the left it's only happening
because it's acceptable these are pcbs
are polychlorinated biphenols there you
go the biphenyls i mean for me some of
this just
makes me have more questions about like
reproduction and human fertility because
if we do believe there's a
genetic link or an environmental
disruption that occurs
where does it come from is it because
you have uh
moms like a generation of moms who've
been on birth control for longer and
that disrupts their hormones which
disrupts how their
fetus i mean i don't know anything about
medical science so this is all
speculation on my part i defer to the
doctor but i wonder if
ultimately
we just don't know
what causes any of these issues because
we are not studying it holistically like
we are looking at it as social
intervention when they reach school but
what if this is something that has to do
with mom's nutrition yeah and you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna back pedal a
little bit so i i
what you said earlier resonates with me
in terms of
you know in terms of attention on
studying it and i'll tell you that just
to your point
one of the problems right with these hot
button issues is that it becomes taboo
to even ask the questions right and
that's a problem
yep i like looking at what i do know is
that pharmaceutical companies are
administering for-profit surgeries and
chemicals in reaction to whatever is
happening that's very apparent yeah
for-profit medical industry there's no
incentive to not encourage if you have
kids that you're treating for more and
more things plus when you go on hormones
there are side effects you take more
medication i mean like this becomes a
mass industry in and of itself why would
you discourage it if you're a
pharmaceutical person not to be too
conspiratorial oh there's no conspiracy
about pharmaceutical companies pursuing
profit over everything else it is well
documented we we've heard it from a
doctor well we uh we pointed out there's
a an article about goldman sachs they
said they were advising pharmaceutical
companies i think i could be wrong
because we don't have the article pulled
up but they were saying curing diseases
is not a long-term you know financial
gain for us yeah yeah yeah that like
you're better off just treating the
symptoms and letting people stay sick
which is just so horrifying yeah
well i it's like i don't want to call
them medical companies anymore i want to
call because the real medicine in my
opinion is food like if you're eating
the right diet you know that's what
hippocrates said the first doctor let
food be thy medicine thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8
and we'll see you all there